Lafe we truly appreciate your father's
work here in Texas would you ever
consider a career in politics well I
appreciate that there's just a deserve I
understand my dad is a US congressman
now he's a freshman US congressman from
Texas district 36 in Southeast Texas and
I'm very proud of him he retired after a
career as a small-town dentist you know
business selling this over Army and Air
Force Army Army and Air Force veteran
and he was fed up with Washington and
didn't like the options that he saw you
know that he knew we're gonna be running
for that seat and he said you know what
I'm throwing my hat in the ring I'm
gonna go up there I'm trying to make a
difference and I we need more people
like that in Washington dad is my dad is
there to make a difference and only to
make it he doesn't care about a career
he doesn't care about being there for
decades and decades and decades you know
he's he's retired and he'd rather be
fishing and hanging out these grandkids
and hunting but he would but he gives up
he cares about the country and he is
sacrificing to be there and to lead and
I'm damn proud of the job that he's
doing and stepping up what I consider a
career in politics I can't imagine
anything to be more miserable than that
you know what on the other hand when I
look at our nation just as my dad has as
felt you know call to do that to step up
to lead you know if we don't do it who's
gonna do it so somebody's got to step up
somebody's got a lead and I think when
you look at the direction of our country
right now and the the the political
climate and and all that's going on you
know in this electoral cycle what I do
that
maybe I just might be able to be talked
into it well we shall see
what about you Joe go get some well I
mean we got we got the bumper stickers
right 2060 we don't see that go Charles
I think I would be running as if I was
to run for political office I would run
as dictator
and he's a premolar of America and
that's why I said what I would do we
could bring back some of the Roman rule
to try and triumvirate so me you and
Ecko we could just take take over I
don't know if I have the stomach for
politics I I really don't like the
political arena too much and not sure
it's something I would ever ever have
the desire to do you know I guess that's
mine that's where I sit maybe when I was
70 years old
yeah people people have asked me to you
know like hey if you were president what
would you do you know about the
situation with Iran you know in their
development of nuclear weapons or China
getting you know making big moves in the
South China Sea or Russia pushing the
envelope and and and kind of thumb when
their noses at us and often I've told
him that if I were president I would
immediately nominate Jaco willing as
Secretary of Defense we would change
secretary defense to the previous title
of Secretary of War and and I think
those problems would would disappear
immediately I think if I was president
it'd be very smooth my policy would be
pretty simple my policy would be
kick-ass that's what we would do
economic we can you act put your
economic plan jaakko kick ass but what's
your what would you do with this
situation over here in the Middle East
oh there oh yeah we're gonna do theirs
we're gonna kick ass what about the drug
problem that we got coming in through
the borders oh the the drug cartel yeah
we're gonna kick ass on that so that
that's my policy
that's like it so this is why I probably
wouldn't be the best politician they're
kind of like DTF yeah anything